Today, the creative team is coming up to the farm,
and we are going to do some content and photographs
for products that are on the website right now.
So we are shooting it in a little barn on the property.
This barn has a beautiful window,
some natural light, and some nice wood walls.
So we brought all the products up there.
We got the sourdough kit out,
we got the beeswax candles.
Even Willow was somehow bubbling in this barn.
It was so cold in the barn today.
We were so impressed
that Willow was still bubbling throughout the photo shoot.
One of my favorite parts about the photo shoot today
was just seeing all of our products together,
working together to make something so beautiful.
Our sourdough kit, for instance,
has been one of our pillar products for a long time.
These are some French jams that we got in seasonally for the holidays,
and they are literally the most beautiful tasting.
So delicious. I'm so excited about these.
Got our beautiful salts hand harvested from France.
Another perk with today's photo shoot is that we got to eat everything.
After we photographed it,
we sprinkled the vanilla Bourbon French salt on the sourdough cookies,
and then we knew as soon as we did that we got to eat them.
But what I didn't realize
is that the cookies actually froze to the cookie sheet.
It was so cold in the barn,
but we ate them, and They were still so good frozen.
All these products are products that I use at home in my kitchen,
and I love them, and I'm just excited to share them with you.
We now have a build your own box option on the website.
So you can go on the website and choose any cuts that you like,
and you can build your own box,
which is so exciting.
We were getting very cold by the end of the afternoon.
We could barely use our fingers,
so we knew it was time to wrap up.
We ended the photo session with our jerky,
which is just beef and French salt,
two ingredients which we love.
We got in the truck, cranked up the heater,
and ended the afternoon with some warm bone broth and a